also get you lizzo you can come and
shine me babes I love that I love that
Poncho Co oh yeah nice Adele One Night
Only was a star-studded affair and we're
talking a-listers people I feel very
lucky on Sunday Adele brought the house
down with her two-hour CBS primetime
special which was partly filmed in Los
Angeles at the Griffith Observatory in
front of an audience filled with some of
Hollywood's biggest celebs I wanted to
feel safe
um in my first little comeback thing so
I wanted to make sure people that I know
and love people that I've met a few
times and some of you I don't know at
all but hi look real close and you'll
spot Leonardo DiCaprio standing up to
applaud the Grammy winner wearing a
baseball cap a blue face mask and a
black hoodie this is a rare sort of
occurrence Seth Rogen was also in
attendance with his wife Lauren Miller
there they are grinning ear to ear and
honestly who can blame them it's the
Adele effect no that's amazing Drake
proved that game recognizes game he was
seen standing up applauding and
seemingly loving every second of Adele's
performance and I felt blessed Jesse
Tyler Ferguson was at the event with his
hubby Justin Makita oh my gosh Ava
devernay was there too seated next to
Gail King and Adele's boyfriend sports
agent Rich Paul and that's not even the
half of it well we could be here a while
Melissa McCarthy took her 14 year old
daughter Vivian to the show and when
Adele helped a fan pull off a surprise
engagement will you marry me hello
Ashley in real in real life
yeah yeah
the bridesmaid star was feeling all the
feels I'm glad you didn't let me eat I
would have thrown up
Gordon Ramsay Selena Gomez Donald Glover
Tyler Perry and Ellen DeGeneres were
there you know it's the greatest thing
as were Gabrielle Union Dwyane Wade
Molly Shannon Aaron Paul lizzo and James
Corden I'm not gonna lie I'm incredibly
humbled by it of course The Late Late
Show host is a good friend of Adele's in
fact he's such a good friend that during
Adele's 73 question segment with Vogue
she revealed he gifted her with a
special Memento from her favorite singer
Celine Dion
James Corden who's a friend of mine but
also does carpool karaoke which I did uh
he did it with her and knew how much a
fan of her I was and so he made her spit
her come into piece of paper and he
framed it for me and it's my proudest
possession and while the audience may
have been packed with star power there
was one person that mattered most to
Adele her nine-year-old son Angelo who
watched his mom perform live for the
very first time it's the absolute honor
of my life baby to have you here tonight
and you look so beautiful and so
handsome and smart of course Oprah
Winfrey was also there to watch Adele
wow the crowd and during her sit-down
interview with the hello singer Adele
revealed that her highly anticipated new
album 30 is dedicated to her son and how
Adam's not about him it's about me
and I just wanted for him to hear me
talking mad madly deeply about who I am
and how I feel like you know and I don't
know if I'd ever be able to have that
conversation with him in real life
[Music]